now if you're pretty observant gadget
hound like me you may be wondering how
is it that these bucket breakdowns
actually work my Nexus 7 tablet for
example is only 800 pixels wide in the
portrait orientation this galaxy s4
phone is actually 1080 pixels wide in
the same dimension even though the s4
has more pixels it's somehow turning up
as a phone why is this the answer lies
in a little bit of magic called the
device pixel ratio and the fact that
once again the web platform is lying to
you the device pixel ratio is the ratio
between device-independent pixels and an
actual physical pixel on the screen
remember back in the viewport lesson
when I said you should just give this
magic boilerplate at the top of your
file and you'd get the actual number of
pixels on the screen as your width well
that's not actually quite true because
we have a concept called a device
independent pixel the first time this
really came into play was when Apple
released the iPhone 4 the original
iPhone and the iPhone 3G and 3GS at a
screen resolution of 320 by 480 the
iPhone 4 however had what Apple called a
Retina display which doubled the
horizontal and vertical resolution to
640 by 960 but they still wanted text
set in pixels to be the same height to
go back to the viewport lesson for a
second even with width set to device
width they still wanted to have the same
pixel width fed to the layout algorithm
so you got consistent layout across the
iPhone 3 an iPhone 4 in essence they
caused the layout algorithm to lie again
even though the screen is actually 640
by 960 the layout algorithm treats it
like it's 320 by 480 that way sizes that
are formatted for the original 320 by
480 screen still layout well on the
higher resolution screen and text and
images are rendered at the higher
resolution so it can look better as well
that's why even on the iPhone 5 if you
set a viewport width device-width the
browser width is returned to you as 320
pixels
not the actual 640 pixels there are
across the screen there are two device
pixels for every pixel that the system
lays out the new screen of course is a
little bit longer so the vertical
dimension is different window dot device
pixel ratio captures this ratio the
number of device pixels for every
formating pixel in the layout system
it's basically a way to identify the
density of pixels on the screen now this
may not be the precise device pixel
density it's sometimes rounded to the
nearest integer but this lets us know
how high-resolution density the screen
is rather than just how many layout
pixels there are on it so let's go back
to the original question how is it that
the galaxy s4 is getting the phone
layout in our conference app while my
Nexus 7 is getting the tablet layout
even though the s4 has a couple hundred
more pixels across than the Nexus and
we're using pixel count to switch in our
media query while the answer is device
pixel ratio the galaxy s4 has a device
pixel ratio of three the Nexus 7 is only
1.3 so if you look at the formatting
width the width passed into the viewport
the window screen width well on the s4
it's 360 but on the Nexus 7 its 601